I'm always looking for a quick and easy
dinner so on this episode of one dirty
dish I'm making a one pot creamy Tuscan
pasta that comes together in less than
40 minutes after melting some butter
you'll cook a shallot and garlic then
add in tomato paste paprika and dried
oregano toast that for a few minutes and
then add in chicken broth milk pasta
cherry tomatoes and sundried tomatoes
season with a little salt and pepper and
let that come to a boil then reduce to a
simmer and cook for about 18 to 20
minutes or until the pasta is Al Dente I
asked patouille Tasty's AI Sue Chef in
the tasty app for one pot dinner
inspiration and he suggested a few great
recipes that this dish based on I'm
shocked I didn't know what to expect
because that was so easy but this is
absolutely delicious